yo Lamar tell me about the craziest
night of your life that was not the
night we all know about where you almost
lost your life give me like peek party
in Lamar is it a bunch of women are you
having a foursome are you what what's
going on I think they're crazy is not oh
I think Chloe she came into this
[ __ ] hotel room at the
Roosevelt okay you and Chloe no I was at
the hotel room with some other women oh
she came and told tell them she started
beating a [ __ ] ass
Dr Roosevelt so you're in the room with
just one or two I forgot how many women
it was more than one though for sure
possibly could have been more so Chloe
finds out you're there yeah I don't know
how the folks you know I was there
though because she's a woman
how you know which hotel
because she she probably knows people
bro she's Khloe Kardashian Sprite you
know slipped the guy at the front desk
that I don't know okay so you're
cheating on Chloe yeah
she shows up what happens next
I don't know she just started [ __ ] a
girl up Jesus we got the whole at The
Roosevelt Hotel I had to like get her
off the girl
I'm sorry I'm thinking about oh this
girl gonna press charges right
TMZ
but you know I got to got the guy off
the ground
did you guys end up like
the girl never went to the police
oh she was a real one oh I can't I wish
I could remember who it was
um
how many times because you know you and
Chloe had a a relationship that I think
was uh we got to watch it on TV people
love y'all you know what I'm saying
people loved y'all together
were you like I mean like obviously you
cheated but like how many times you get
caught cheating
by Chloe
too
that's not bad she seems like a
forgiving person she is
she wiped my eyes when I was
recover yeah